i have water throughout the day and then
when i actually get really really really
hungry like i feel like i'm gonna break
up with my 17 boyfriend flee the country
fire all my editors then i decide it's
finally time to eat oh dear
i see why this got deleted hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be reviewing the very
controversial highly requested and now
deleted blair walnuts video how to lose
weight fast 20 pounds in three months
exclamation mark exclamation mark but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
build bar so let's have a survey
do you like protein that tastes like
chalk um
no because i definitely do not and that
my friends is why i love build bars
because they actually taste like
chocolate because they're made with
actual chocolate but bonus there's a lot
of protein in them which we love
so today's
flavor i just bust into a new box like
i'm feeling myself
what do i feel like is the question
mint fruity
chocolatey
guys it's friday today when i'm filming
this it's friday then
this saturday sunday what
it's friday night
and so i'm feeling
the cookies and cream
this is my favorite
[Applause]
i may have chocolate
on my face
but i don't care
um so this bad boy 17 grams of protein
it's so good like chopped up on yogurt
or sometimes what i do is i melt it in
the microwave for 10 seconds and then i
put whipped cream on it
my mouth is still watering
oh so good i actually usually have one
before bed but if i were to do this as
like a post workout snack in the morning
i would throw in some fruit or oats as
well so if you want to try these out
yourself check out the link in my
description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 for 50
off of your order
okay i cannot forget here huge trigger
warning that you can read in my
description or right here this is
actually a pretty triggering video um
she mentions hard numbers shows body
pictures and also some of her tips can
be easily interpreted as disordered
eating so
please please please skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey
i'm not leaving and if you are new here
please ring this bell ring this bell
ring this bell and subscribe so that you
never miss out on an episode okay so i
actually reviewed blair walnut's diet
about a year ago
and if you remember i was actually quite
supportive of her intuitive non-diet
approach to food she seemed to be all
about enjoying the food that she really
loved and eating what felt good to her
body and outside of her satirical
comments about like being a skinny
legend
there really wasn't a lot of weight diet
or wellness talk but it seems a lot has
changed since then
now if you're a regular here you know
that i don't make judgments or share
opinions on people's body face or really
anything else aesthetic
i believe in body autonomy and doing
whatever feels best for your body
whether that's intentional weight loss
plastic surgery photoshopping images etc
though there is a caveat to this which
i'm going to be discussing in this video
in just a moment but what i do take
issue with is the spreading of really
triggering misinformation and disordered
advice so a lot of you like a lot a lot
a lot of you sent me this blair walnuts
video on her tips on how she lost 20
pounds in three months insisting that it
was triggering as [ __ ]
i figured i better get to it stat and
because i had a feeling when i watched
it that it was so bad that it was gonna
get taken down
i screen recorded it ahead of time so in
the past when an influencer has taken
down a video i've tried not to comment
on it thinking you know they probably
feel remorseful and they realize they've
done something wrong
so maybe they've had a change of heart
themselves in their position
but in this case
that video racked up so many views and
so many of your views i know this
because i got so many requests from you
about this video telling me that it like
completely shook you
i thought
my god like the damage is done this
information has been out there people
have absorbed it people have listened to
it people are ruminating on it
i need to take it down and help you make
sense of this all so
we're going there but i first want to
answer the age-old question
is 20 pounds in three months even
safe so that amounts to approximately
1.7 pounds a week which is within the
one to two pound loss per week that most
experts recommend
though i will say that this is a quite
significant loss for a straight sized
woman like blair
so i would be curious how much of that
weight is fat loss versus water and
metabolic muscle and i also would be
concerned about weight regain
so research suggests that losing weight
too quickly is associated with metabolic
declines nutrition deficiencies muscle
loss dehydration and mental health
disturbances so it's really important to
find a way of eating that you feel that
you can sustain for life how did you
lose so much weight so fast so basically
i went from 147 pounds to 130 pounds in
a couple months and i'll show you all my
secrets and how i'm able to keep it off
without really trying or putting in any
effort because i'm a low effort kind of
gal lately
okay no exercise no dieting no thinking
about it no effort girl you are killing
it
with the clickbait i am like dying to
know this secret here because it sounds
a little too good to be true the most
important thing that i think that i do
is intermittent fast sometimes on
accident it helps me save my calories
for like later in the day right so i
typically don't eat breakfast i just
have coffee if i do eat breakfast it's
around 12 1 2 3. okay so yes this is
textbook intermittent fasting but as i
discussed in my intermittent fasting
video right here
it's often counterproductive to use this
method to kind of save your calories for
later on in the day
not only is this a setup for a binge
which explains why it's not uncommon for
people to not lose weight or even to
gain weight while intermittent fasting
but we also know that there's evidence
that there are metabolic and blood sugar
regulation benefits to consuming the
bulk of your calories in the earlier
part of the day rather than later on
in other words if you really want to
optimize your fasting window
eat all of your meals earlier on in the
day
but i also know that there's a lot of
social and psychological reasons why
that isn't so easy for most people to
have like a 4 pm dinner which is why all
of these are moot points because i don't
recommend intermittent fasting at all
for most folks
shocker i know i try to just have
espresso or a double espresso or a
triple espresso in the morning hot with
nothing else i have water throughout the
day and then when i actually get really
really really hungry like i feel like
i'm going to break up with my 17
boyfriends flee the country fire all my
editors then i decide it's finally time
to eat anything i feel like but usually
it's fruit or eggs um or i just start
with like lunch okay
i'm not sure if my bar for
low effort is significantly lower than
blair's but
what about getting so hungry that you're
considering fleeing the country and
leaving your 17 boyfriends says
low effort
to you
i mean i know she's joking but
it seems so emotionally and physically
exhausting to take that roller coaster
every day just to eat some eggs and
fruit like
gosh talk about not worth that drama at
least give the girl some pancakes or
like a pan of cinnamon buns am i right
perhaps you're right so i don't actually
count my calories but i do hack my
calories try not to eat highly caloric
food i really watch it with chips and
guac right other things i watch it with
is like peanut butter ice cream
everything that's really high calories i
kind of like avoid i mean
if weight loss is the goal then yes
calories do absolutely matter and being
mindful of your portion sizes for those
high calorie lower nutrient items like
chips candy ice cream etc is probably a
smart plan but some of the foods on her
no no list
are really nutrient dense foods that
while higher in calories are also highly
satiating because they're loaded with
hunger crushing compounds so guac for
example is rich in healthy fats and
fiber and peanut butter has fiber
protein and healthy fats so while we may
want to be more mindful of portion sizes
of these nutrient-dense foods while
trying to lose weight
i don't think we want people to think
that they need to cut them out
completely when i eat at a restaurant i
try to either go for salad with no
cheese very little dressing raw foods a
salmon pokeball with no rice i try to go
for fish and vegetables or meats and
vegetables restaurants unfortunately put
a lot of oil and butter in our food so
sometimes when i'm ordering eggs and the
restaurant is a little sauce to me i get
hard-boiled eggs because i can't add oil
to those oh wow
i see why so many of you tagged me here
so
yes oils are calorically dense so again
we want to be mindful of oil portions
and i know that's obviously more
challenging when you're eating out but
blair i have to just say that this is
very much sounding like advice that you
would find on a pro and a reddit site
like this is exactly what i would have
done when i was really struggling with
my eating disorder because it was the
only way i could control or know how
many calories i was eating so like
ordering hard-boiled eggs not because
you liked hard-boiled eggs but because
you know that the restaurant can't sneak
in any unknown calories
kind of a big red flag to me so blair
might not be counting her calories
but instead she's fearfully choosing
foods that are as low in calories as
possible without any regard for balance
or actual nutrition
i'm not sure that's a better or
healthier or even easier way to go
actually i know it's not i'm really
trying to wash my calories and i'm
eating out all day i'll get hard-boiled
eggs for breakfast with avocado and
tomato on the side and fruits like some
kind of raw fish tuna tartare with just
greens and then for dinner i'll do like
a soup and a salad like i try to keep
things very light
okay so
breakfast
i mean it's a bit boring but at least we
have some balance with the protein in
the eggs we get healthy fats and fiber
in the avocado and some more fiber and
carbs in the fruit but considering she's
likely breaking a super long fast
with that
i worry that that's just not enough
now lunch we've got maybe some protein
and also maybe a bit of healthy fats in
the fish but we definitely need some
carb action to round that out like poke
bowls without any rice have around 200
calories like that's just not a meal
and then to follow that up with just
some low calorie soup and some more
vegetables in the salad with no protein
and probably also not a lot of fat
again that's a few hundred calories tops
and when i do the math that's no more
than likely like a thousand calories a
day compared to my notes on her previous
what in a day review where she was
eating around 2000 calories and i know
that this is just her recounting her
meals so it's very rough estimate here
but that's potentially a 1000 calorie
deficit
like
what the [ __ ] do you like french fries
though i'll have like french fries and
mayonnaise and that'll be like my meal
okay i love french fries and i think
that you can absolutely still lose
weight while enjoying french fries in
your week
but like
in addition to an actual meal
not as
a meal like some french fries on their
own are not a meal
and forcing yourself to stay hungry just
to accommodate eating some french fries
is not
low effort to me
it's potentially dangerous and
disorderly behavior
and honestly ask anyone who's had an
actual eating disorder
it takes an enormous amount of effort
to keep that up and i'm not saying that
blair has an eating disorder at all i'm
saying that this advice in the wrong
hands
is very dangerous
when i'm out and i order a side of mac
and cheese and i share with my friends
that's another tip i have for you guys
share with your friends let them eat
most of the work
so
i think it's always great advice to
share food with friends but ordering a
small side of mac and cheese for the
table and having your friends consume
most of it so that you can create the
facade of participating in the social
foodie fun without eating more than a
few dozen calories
is problematic
warm liquids keep your stomach full i
love hot tea hot anything t just hot
water with lemon just hot water by
itself soups like bone broth if there is
a vegetable soup on the menu get it if
there is some kind of like brothy soup
get it okay so it's a classic diet tip
to start your meal with a broth-based
soup or to drink a ton of water before a
meal
because it will temporarily stretch your
stomach trigger your vagus nerve to cue
satiety in your brain
but
when little to no energy is actually
provided in this transaction
this message here is very short-lived
and you're back to being really hangry
again soon after so please
blair and everybody else who's watching
the only way to effectively hack your
hunger
is to eat calories like to eat food or
to drink calories whatever
but this is your body begging for energy
so
please girl just
just listen to it
and respond help me
help
me a cup of hot water and then eat lunch
sometimes i have a tendency to overeat
friends that i'm talking and just
stuffing my face so if i drink a little
bit of hot water before i will eat the
portions i'm supposed to be eating so
who said that these are the portions
you're supposed to be eating
because i would guess that if you're
stuffing your face
it's not because you're just excited to
be with your friends
it's likely because your body is
starving and deprived and you need that
food guys please stop trying to trick
yourself with all these stupid hacks
your body is gonna hack that hack i
don't count my calories i eat between
1500 and 000 calories a day probably i
mean here's hoping but
i would say that that's not what it
sounds like based on all these
hacks
the reason why i edit my body especially
on thumbnails and things like that is
because even if i have a good message in
the video if nobody clicks on it and
nobody hears my good message what's the
point of my good message right
okay
gotta be succinct here first of all
i think that heavy photo editing on
social media can in some ways be ageist
fatphobic and can contribute to young
viewers insecurities in the pursuit of
aesthetic perfection
but i don't think it's fair to suggest
that these things causely lead to eating
disorders or body dysmorphia i believe
that their use is more of a symptom of a
societal problem
not the source of the problem itself
so as blair points out herself it's
something that she feels that she kind
of has to do because everybody else does
it unfortunate yes but also i would say
a fair point and while some countries
have actually banned photo editing like
this
i do worry that that may be
oversimplifying the problem what i think
is a more realistic ask is that the same
way that we as content creators have to
disclose our sponsorships i think we
need mandatory disclosure of like heavy
photo editing when claims about our body
are being made so i don't think that
everyone needs to shout out to the world
that they've had plastic surgery like i
just think our body is no one else's
business and we're really all entitled
to do whatever we want to it and to keep
it to ourselves if we want
but
when an influencer is claiming that some
manual effort on their part aka diet or
exercise alone has resulted in the after
photo that they're sharing
i think it's deceptive not to call out
when surgery or heavy photo editing has
played a role so i guess if anything i
give the girl props for being
transparent about what she does
and i guess i wish that other
influencers kardashians
would ultimately do the same now my
second point is that it's always been my
position as a content creator that we
sometimes need to use clickbait to get
the right people to hear our message
which is also what blair is saying here
but in this case
i just need to say that
honey
this is not a good message to spread
like labeling her body on the left as
fat and juxtaposition of her skinny body
on the right in the thumbnail
is insensitive and triggering for a lot
of folks so i think that in this case
the combination of blair's edited
thumbnail the title and the content
itself
is toxic as [ __ ]
and doesn't serve anyone well sorry not
sorry i don't go to the gym but i do
walk a lot i will not have a day where i
just sit in the room without walking i
absolutely refuse you know what else
counts as walking though dancing okay so
first of all what i like i like that
blaire is recommending a joyful activity
like dancing or even walking if that is
more enjoyable and sustainable than
going to the gym but i don't love that
she's so hell bent and hardcore on never
ever having a day where she doesn't walk
like
what if she's sick
what if she's injured
what if it's a holiday or it's a really
busy travel day and there are other
self-care or family or work priorities
that need attention
having a healthy relationship with
exercise means exercising flexibility
and body kindness and trusting that our
body isn't going to go to shock
just because we missed one day of
activity
don't focus on food i feel that it makes
me very food conscious and restrictive
and it's really unhealthy for my own
brain i become really obsessed with food
to the point where after i finish eating
i'll think about my next meal i'd rather
drink hot water get breakfast because
i'm not hungry chicken breast with
broccoli and rice i have to measure it
and then in the morning the next morning
i can have an omelet you know what i'm
saying i cannot do that so
as i discussed in my video on calorie
counting and that ballerina right here
yeah i also don't think it's
psychologically always healthy for most
people to obsessively count calories
some people can do it and then they just
see it like as data which is great but
for a lot of us that's a monsoon mental
load to try to carry
but
her alternative
is arguably
much
much worse because while you might not
have to do any complex math equations or
log like every byte that you take into
your app
you instead have to constantly find
hacks to keep yourself in a grossly
undernourished state
and the result is that you likely end up
with a severe caloric and nutrient
deficit which puts you at risk of
nutrient deficiencies hormonal
imbalances metabolic disturbances and
weight rebound so this approach may be
easier for blair
but i think it's very very dangerous
universal advice
i used to do that and i feel like i just
gained more weight because i would have
five days of perfect 1300 calorie eating
and i would have four days of being out
on the weekend enjoying my life and
that's the balance that really will
screw you over yes there's definitely a
risk of this kind of restrict binge
cycle with any restrictive dieting and
this is why i don't like cheat days
because in addition to the psychological
toll that it takes it's very easy to
undo a weekly caloric deficit with a
massive blowout meal or two
but that risk is really no different
with blair's approach
in fact her protocol seems so physically
restrictive
that i can't imagine that most people
could eat that way for very long without
triggering a binge
if you're craving something go eat it
don't replace it with anything else if
you want mcdonald's go through the
mcdonald's drive-through order whatever
you want try to eat half think that
you're sharing your meal with your kid
and this is the only food you can buy
satisfy your craving i'm sorry she's
telling people to imagine themselves in
a food insecure scenario where they
cannot afford to provide their body and
their child's body with enough fuel as a
low effort hack to cut calories but
at least you get to satisfy your craving
so
it's easy
oh god
if i'm craving pizza i'll order pizza
i'll eat two slices of my favorite most
favorite caloric pizza ever and i'll put
the rest in the fridge and eat it
tomorrow for lunch then you can eat your
favorite meal more times than just one
time of binging and loving it and
feeling sick after and regretting it
okay so i do like this tip in some ways
mainly because i'm all about allowing
yourself your favorite foods to take the
novelty away so that you're less likely
to binge and make yourself feel sick as
blair says but the key here
is
to still eat
enough so i know for me two pieces of
thin crust pizza
not enough for dinner nope
i'mma be hungry and i'll be balls deep
in the family size chip bag soon after
but if i paired that with maybe a big
salad loaded up with satiating add-ins
like some avocado and nuts and chickpeas
and dressing
i will be much more emotionally
satisfied and physically satiated so yes
to having your favorite foods in
moderation every day but also you still
got to eat enough
another tip i have is to not snack when
there is no food in the house i don't
eat i can eat a thousand or 2000
calories in snacks just while i'm
editing the phone and they don't satisfy
me snacks do nothing for me okay
so first of all if the only reason you
are not eating is because you do not
have access to food but when you do have
access to said food you eat a lot
that's a pretty good sign that your body
needs more food
it needs those calories you're hungry
you are deprived
so this is a really [ __ ] pack
and two if snack foods are not
satisfying to you
hunger crush and combo them
so popcorn for example is high in fiber
so you could try pairing it with some
nuts or seeds for more balanced
saturating snack
also we really need to shift our
perspective on what constitutes a snack
you looking like a snack
i i guess i guess i feel cute today a
snack is really just a smaller meal
served between two larger meals there's
nothing stopping us from having
meal-like food like a sandwich at snack
time if that's what's going to
physically or psychologically
satisfy you better
there are a couple supplements i take
there's some like water diuretic pills
another thing i have to recommend you
guys is make sure you're pooping every
day and to make sure you're eating
enough fiber to force yourself to go to
the bathroom fruits and vegetables and
hot water will make you go to the
bathroom every day and cheers
so i'm trying to keep this video
succinct so very simply put
diuretics and fiber
do not speed up your metabolism
if you're peeing and pooping more than
normal you are losing water and waste
water not that and you're not magically
burning more calories at rest which is
what speeding your metabolism up would
entail now diuretic use can also be very
dangerous so i do not recommend doing
this without doctor supervision
everything comes down to poo as for
fiber it's important to note that too
much fiber can actually back you up so
it's a very delicate balance of getting
enough and getting the right types of
fiber without getting too much so if
you're trying to up your fiber intake to
help with regularity make sure that
you're going gradually and of course
make sure that you're drinking a lot of
water and moving your body to help
prevent constipation
well
i think that's all that i can say about
this
i
feel
disappointed but also quite empathetic
towards blair and the fact that she's
headed down this road i mean she seemed
to have such a beautifully balanced
approach to food
so i guess my take home message for all
of you watching is
please
do not follow suit
i mean the physical and psychological
risks of a diet regimen like this
far outweigh
any potential benefit that i could see
i mean the fact that blair took this
video down tells me that maybe she
acknowledges that something here is not
right and please folks please be kind in
the comments you know i feel very
strongly that as content creators we
hold a lot of responsibilities for our
words and our actions but i also want to
acknowledge that you know it's not easy
living so publicly and going about your
food journey in such an open and
transparent way
and on that note that is all for today's
wedding day review
thank you again to bill barr for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who'd like senior few
next subscribe to the channel and i will
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
you